if those of you that are a little bit
new don't know what that means around
here we've been saying for about 20
years if you will live like no one else
later you can live and give like no one
else they pay a price to win you don't
win if you don't pay a price you know
that right the great motivator Les Brown
says people change their lives when they
finally say I've had it I'm sick and
tired of being sick and tired
I've had it things are changing that's
the beginning and then you pay a price
no one accidentally wins at anything if
you meet an old person who's been
married for 53 years and you ask them
how to be married they always tell you
oh it's fun you got to work at it
sometimes she's not that lovable that's
what they'll tell you every time none of
them go oh it's skittles and rainbows
and unicorns and it's all easy and it's
no trouble and it's just its icing on
the cake all the time if they say that
they're lying anybody's been married
more than 10 minutes knows that no I'm
not saying marriage is horrible it's not
I've got a wonderful marriage I'm glad
I'm married I have a great wife 37 years
we've been going so I mean this is all
right but the point is is that anything
you're gonna win at you're gonna work at
no you see these people with these great
bodies I mean physical condition
unbelievable they got an eight-pack you
know they don't have a six-pack they got
an eight pack man I mean they're there
they're jammed you know what I'm talking
about chisel that does not act they
don't accidentally get that I don't wake
up one morning go would you look at that
you know that doesn't happen
no they there's a lot of hours and sweat
and a lot of push ups and push backs
push back from the table and push ups in
the gym right I mean there's a price to
be paid to win at something you got to
live like no one else and then you get
the
like live like and give like no one else
but there's a price to be paid to win
and that's where that lived like no one
else thing comes from the Bible says it
this way in Hebrews no discipline seems
Pleasant at the time but it yields a
harvest of righteousness I did a 6 mile
run this morning because I'm trying to
get ready for this Country Music
Marathon and I've challenged half
marathon I don't do marathons I
challenged my whole team to do it
there's 700 of us and I'm trying to get
at least half of them to do it I got 275
to do it so far
I need to get on the 75 to get us up to
350 350 Ramsey runners in this race
there's 35,000 people so we will
disappear into that crowd but I haven't
run I've run about 15 half marathons of
my life and I haven't run one in five
years I didn't 6 miles this morning it
was ugly it was ugly it was nasty I mean
Dave waddling down the sidewalk calling
it running uh it was ugly my times are
awful I got hurt it's awful
but I got all the way it's not the race
until April 28th so I still got 10 weeks
or whatever I'll make it it's all good
I'll get there
I did six six this morning and I'll be
back up you know didn't take me long and
get back up to six but no discipline
seems Pleasant at the time but it yields
the harvest of righteousness you got to
live like no one else so that later you
can live and give like no one else
very few people wake up and say how did
I become a millionaire I have no idea
now when I talk to these millionaires on
the millionaire theme matter they can
tell you exactly what they did did you
use debt no did you inherit it no what'd
you do I work my butt off for 20 years
and I saved and invested in my 401k and
I got my house paid off that's what they
usually tell me right there if you
listen to these million everything
matters that's what they say over and
over and over again what was your GPA
3.0 you mean you're not a genius no
bright but I'm not a genius
this is what they tell me all the time
very steady methodical process and you
become a millionaire live like no one
else so later you can live and give like
no one else drive a car that no one else
would drive so that later you can drive
a car that no one else can drive that's
fine
it's fine I'm a boy I like cars I got me
some cars but I tell you what when we
were broke you know what I drove a guy
loaned me in 1978 Cadillac with four
hundred and seventy eight thousand
actual miles on it the predominant color
on this puppy was bondo vinyl roof
across the top was torn loose and when I
drove it it filled up with air looked
like a parachute with bondo hanging off
of it I'm driving that thing down the
road the cops are following me wondering
what I'm doing in this in a town in that
car when you doing over here son I'll
live over here no let me see your
aggressive be driving that car it's a
hundred on our car man and they won't
even mine it was loaned to me man I
drove that car for ten years one
three-month period I felt like ten years
there's only three months I still
remember that thing man the Blue Goose
man was a blessing because I've been
walking if I didn't have that it's
smoked it's smoked like like your
mother's chimney man I mean it's smoked
you know as unbelievable fill up with
smoke looked like Cheech and Chong right
along there you know I mean it's
unbelievable I drove that car because I
was never gonna borrow money again you
know I saved during that during that
three months we saved a thousand dollars
and I bought a thousand dollar car I
thought I was rich
I'm not borrowing money anymore ever I'm
gonna live like no one else so later and
live like no one else I drove that
thousand other car for about a year we
bought a three thousand dollar car cash
we drove it for about four months and I
totaled it got $4,000 for it put had
saved a little bit of money and bought a
six thousand dollar car you know what I
Drive now
anything I want if you don't like it you
can kiss my butt I paid a price to get
here but my cars are a very very small
percentage of my income and a very small
percentage of what we give to ministries
into charities every year and if you
don't like the fact I've got a nice car
you can kiss my butt I paid a price to
get there live like no one else later
you can live and give like no one else
we travel I'd stay in the quality inn
there were roaches in there doing ninja
moves
I don't stay in places like that now man
I don't stay in places like that well
you're a snob no I'm not I got the
dadgum money I don't have to put up with
that crap go in someplace and I don't
need it the Golden Corral y'all I'm just
telling you but we ate at Sharon's
restaurant for a long time Sharon's
really good with leftovers I'll tell you
that we paid a price to win you'll pay a
price to win we'll live like no one else
check out this we'll check out this
thing on YouTube y'all this is how it's
done there's no shortcut to any places
worth goin you can do this you live like
no one else later you can live and give
like no one else